you've probably already heard that Apple
is switching over to uspc on their
iPhones but you haven't heard their
master plan of how they're going to make
the most amount of money and this is
unfortunately gonna suck for us now
before I explain how apple is going to
make so much money with USBC I've got to
show you guys the renders or cads of the
iPhone 15 lineup it started off with the
exclusive cads the real case cads the
official ones from Max Weinbach posted
on 95 Max showing the brand new redesign
with thinner bezels on the front it
still has flat sides but now they curve
into the glass for this awesome new look
and design but the main takeaway is USBC
has been confirmed along with that crazy
big camera bump and then we had ice
Universe with the 15 Pro Max CAD files
also showing USBC then we had unknowns
21 on Twitter showing off in a actual
image of the regular iPhone 15 with the
dynamic Island and the new curved
redesign but most important of all we
have an official image of the USBC port
on the bottom of the iPhone 15 and then
finally of course we have the iPhone 15
plus renders revealed just last week
with USBC on the bottom so this
basically confirms that the entire
iPhone 15 lineup will remain the same as
we have with the 14 lineup but with USBC
but there is going to be some massive
massive changes in the way that Apple
pulls it off now first of all I do want
to say that people were in disbelief
about USBC because people know that
Apple made a ton of money from lightning
Yano on medium.com estimated that Apple
was making 43.5 billion dollars on
lightning cable sales alone and that is
of course using their mfi system now
before we move on I've got to show you
guys the best pair of shoes I've ever
had in my life from vesi which are
completely unique because they're 100
waterproof while using a knit material
called dime attacks but the crazy thing
is that they're actually also very light
warm durable comfortable and breathable
all at the same time they're very grippy
on the bottom so I've been wearing them
all winter in the snow and it actually
snowed this morning and I snow blowed my
entire driveway while wearing the
vessies getting a bunch of snow on them
and my socks were completely dry all day
not only that but because they're
waterproof I can literally rinse them
off and clean them under the sink and
the inside stays fully dry in fact I
like these so much that I told my wife I
would never daily wear a different brand
of shoe again and I bought her two pair
is like these slip-on boots which she
loves and they've got a bunch of
different options on the side as well so
check out these vessies and other styles
at vesti.com maxtech and use the code
Max Tech to get 15 off your entire order
today so back in October when Apple
actually did an interview and said that
obviously we have to comply with the
eu's new USBC rules they basically
confirmed that they're switching to USBC
that was a huge surprise but guess what
apple is gonna do to circumvent all of
this shrimp Apple Pro just posted that
yes USBC with mfi is happening and
Foxconn Apple's main manufacturing
supplier is already in mass production
with accessories like the earpods and
cables so somebody asked them what's
going to be the difference between mfi
and stock standard USBC well he said
cables with no mfi will be software
Limited in data and charging speeds and
they asked will Apple's mfi cables work
with Android phones yes in theory they
will because it's still PD charging and
then even further this morning he said
it's going to be basically the same as
lightning mfi and how it all works right
now so what does all of this mean well
it means that apple is getting their
money regardless of lightning USBC it
doesn't matter apple is forcing you to
use mfi if you want the best experience
and they're gonna get paid for it and to
further explain how it works if you have
an accessory maker that wants to make a
fully supported accessory with a new
USBC Port meant for the iPhone like
let's say a game controller anything
else like that they're gonna have to pay
Apple a fee to unlock the full
performance so essentially if you have a
bunch of USBC cables laying around and
you're like yes I'm finally upgrading to
the iPhone 15 it has USBC I'm going to
use all these cables it's going to be
amazing well you're gonna have a limited
experience because according to shrimp
Apple Pro USBC cables without the mfi
badge may have the data transfer and
charging speed limited and this is a
really big deal because the iPhone 15
Pro is rumored to have a thunderbolt
port with significant
over lightning so for example we could
get 40 gigabit per second transfer
speeds with Thunderbolt 3 while
currently lightning is literally limited
to USB 2.0 speeds with only up to 480
megabits that's literally 83 times
faster if the iPhone 15 Pro actually
gets Thunderbolt and that's only if
you're using Apple's mfi USBC cable
that's going to be more expensive so
back in November Ming should quote did
confirm that only the 15 Pro Models are
going to support the higher speed data
transfers which might not even mean
Thunderbolt maybe it's just the basic
USB 3.2 which is also very very fast but
the downside is that he says the
standard 15 and 15 plus might still just
support USB 2.0 the same as lightning
and that is absolutely terrible so if if
you're wondering how all of this is
going to work well let's look at Apple's
current wireless macsafe chargers that
they have right now most of the third
party accessories that you see online
like on Amazon they have magnetic
charging support but it's only limited
to 7.5 watt charging now however there
are some other products that do support
the fastest charging like this one from
Nomad or this one from anchor but they
are expensive partly because they have
to pay Apple a licensing fee and they
have to buy the actual 15 watt Max save
coil package or unit to use for those
expensive accessories so essentially
you're gonna have to buy an Apple mfi
certified Thunderbolt cable if you want
those transfer speeds on the 15 Pro
Models assuming they get that feature
otherwise any regular cable is gonna
give you slow transfer speeds and now on
the charging side of things it's been
confirmed that that the 13 Pro Models
and the 14 pro models are limited to 27
watts of fast charging so what if Apple
gives us the new iPhone 15 Pro Models
with 40 watt fast charging but only if
you use their cable now of course
they're going to include a cable in the
Box most likely but when you go to buy a
new one a replacement one or if you use
some kind of other USBC cable lying
around like at your friend's house
you're not going to get the full fast
charging it could just be limited to 27
Watts or it could be even worse what if
they keep it at the same 27 watt fast
charging limit but they bring it down to
20 if you're using a third-party USBC
cable so just look at all these cables
you could be using at these lower prices
and you've got Apple's version right
here 19 the most expensive one you're
gonna have to pay that to get the
fastest charging and transfer speeds and
now let's get into the Apple business
side of things how does Apple make money
and exactly how much do they make well
for all of Apple's mfi certified
accessories like for example the
lightning Port itself or the cable Apple
charges a flat four dollar rate per
connector so when you see an official
mfi lightning connector on a device or
on a cable the manufacturer had to pay
four dollars per connector which is kind
of a lot because if you take a look at
Amazon at all these cheap USBC cables
they're going to be even more expensive
they're not going to be able to get this
cheap because the companies have to keep
their profit margins so all of the
official mfi cables will be more
expensive and this doesn't just apply to
lightning cables and connectors they're
doing this for everything like their
Apple watch charger modules that they
have car keys air Play Gym kit home kit
iPod mfi game controllers and of course
their Max safe case module and charger
modules and that is where apple is going
in the future I believe that we're gonna
have three years of USBC iPhones at
least and as soon as 2026 we might get a
fully portless iPhone no Port no USBC no
lightning no port at all on the bottom
it's just gonna use wireless Mac safe
charging and as you can see these things
are expensive 34 on sale for an official
15 watt Max save charger and Apple's
gonna be making their money with
Wireless Max safe just like they're
doing with lightning right now and
they're about to do with USB type-c
making a bunch of mfi royalties and the
way it's going to work is with this
official Apple patent which shows off
Wireless Max safe but with data transfer
included as you can see in this patent
image right here using light to transfer
data to a different macsafe Puck that
connects to your computer that's how
they're going to get it done and of
course they're going to make a ton of
money because these charges are
expensive 34 on sale so they're gonna be
making money on this just like they're
doing with lightning right now and
they're about to do with mfi USB type c
The House Always Wins Apple always wins
no wonder they're switching to USBC on
their iPhones let me know what you think
down in the comment section below and if
you enjoyed this video definitely click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign